was a hell of a game and the ads brought
their a game as well talking about
reaction maybe Oh before we get into the
individual ads this writ large what was
happening in social media as it was
reacting to the Commerce going on
between plays yeah so what Tom what
we're seeing now is appetites have a lot
notes as to where to show there at the
days of sort of a TV ad and a bit of
buzz in the newspaper the next day are
clearly long gone you have advertisers
thinking about launching their videos
before the game extending their video
after the game trying to generate shares
and likes and and you know engagement
for a much longer period of time and and
it also doesn't means it got choice so
it's not just TV but there's a whole
load of ways to spend your money so as
we look through some of those ads what
what what reaction we listed out to you
with what happened online so what we saw
is a lot of ads were actually put up on
YouTube for example quite a long time in
advance of the game and others were put
up just shortly before the game and no
surprise in one area is that a lot of
the ads when they were shown on on
during TV suddenly the youtube views
started taking off like crazy and we saw
that with for example a coca-cola rat
had very few views beforehand then did
incredibly well pretty much when it end
I think that was that was part of their
plan you had others like Budweiser
launch their add a few days in advance
they already had over 10 million views
before the game even started and then he
got another great surge you know during
the game so you're seeing different
strategies from different brands around
do you use a super bowl to launch
something and sustain it online or
actually build up excitement and
knowledge of the ad in advance and then
the Super Bowl is just one milestone
amongst many during the campaign yeah
sort of the touchy-feely ads the
budweiser ads the horses and dogs and
puppies even what could possibly won't
be wrong with that but there was some
sort of clever too and I wonder in that
mass audience how clever plays you know
t-mobile with their Kim Kardashian had
it was you know it was funny or wasn't
funny for those one of these I thought
me and I wonder if that's the kind of
add that is designed with the social
media sponsorship behind it to get that
message out all over the place after
that runs it may be I mean it all seems
a lot of ways to judge you know is
something really resonating benefitting
with social media one of the quick early
polls it was the sort of consumer vote
what did well I think that ad came about
half way whereas Budweiser came you know
towards the top so I think in terms of
the early indication we don't know what
we monitor at things like the completion
rate of people watch something online do
they finish it that means they like it
the share rate etc right now there's a
pretty close correlation between what
consumers are saying in surveys and
who's getting the best engagement in
terms of sa completion and shares and
and other things so I think t-mobile
maybe was intended to be a great sharing
type of video doesn't seem to be
resonating yet I think that the bad one
is is in the clearly the BMW ad is doing
pretty well for the night free the
coca-cola one arm is doing well but
we're going to monetize over a few days
because what you see is in the early
days after super bowl of Baptizer to
spend a lot of money to get shares at
some stage those campaigns end and then
we'll be seeing who carries on being
viewed after the budgets end and that's
a sign of a really good add that really
resonates that people will share you
know just because they loved it it was
interesting to see you know who was
going for the cheeky who was going for
the sexy I was interesting the
Victoria's Secrets you know that people
watch this game with their families
wives watch this with their husbands
there's more sort of a mixed audience
and your typical football game and I
wonder how that plays differently online
um yeah I guess obviously online you can
have a much more targeted message
because online you can target men or
women or rich people or poor people or
in people with kids people without kids
so when you have some of this design for
digital you tend to define your target
audience much more narrowly than you
design something for TV and
sweat sort of the super bowl ads in
general are design for a mass audience
and that's why cooking your brands that
are relevant to a lot of diverse
consumers like coca-cola tend to do very
well I in many ways I'm surprised that
the car companies still spent so much
money on Super Bowl when online you can
target rival board your car who have an
affinity with your brand on a planet by
car in the next year on to that you
going Ben let me ask really quickly we
had the Carl's jr. CEO on last week with
cke CEO and he talked about how his
daddy was buying regional space as
opposed to the national ad not just
because he's got two different brands in
East Coast Brandon a west coast Brandon
Hardy's versus Carl's jr. but also that
he just felt he could target the markets
we could have the most impact still
benefit from being on the super bowl and
but generate the sort of social media
buzz is that may be a model will see
more of last question yes it is and what
we're seeing across the spectrum of TV
but in particular with some digital
videos is more and more narrow targeting
to the point where we're seeing
advertisers now instead of making one
out a year we'll make 10 or 20 ads a
year and different ads up with different
demographics or you can have ads for
loyal customers versus ask customers you
can really get precise and people has to
be with that so things like regional ads
and other things are a step in that
direction play